to grow okay when I have a look at Part
II this looks even worse than what you
started with and you might think to
myself my goodness like if I want to
deal with each term individually like I
did with the previous question I'm gonna
have to expand this it looks like a
terrible mess look how high those
indices get but you don't need to expand
this you don't need to if you look
carefully you'll see that there's some
structure within this question that
allows you to avoid expanding all
together have a look at these these two
things have been multiplied together
you've got 45 x squared plus 100x and
then you've got this 3x cubed plus 10x
squared now I want to look carefully at
these two different functions and I
wonder if you notice there's a
relationship for example you can see
here that the power here compared to the
power here it's one less right and the
power here compared to the power here
that's a 1 that's hiding there
it's also one less you also have let's
highlight this you got this guy here
which is a multiple of three you got
this
which is a multiple of three and then
lastly you've got this 100 which is a
multiple of 10 so there is meant to be a
relationship between everything in this
set of brackets and everything in this
set of brackets so I've just turned this
into a rainbow mess let's clean that up
now to see the connection more clearly I
want you to consider this guy as f of X
if that were f of X then F dash X would
equal think about it carefully I'm gonna
bring the power of the index down three
becomes 9x squared reducing the index by
one and then I'm gonna have the second
one which is 20x because I brought that
to index down the bottom and multiplied
it by 10 to give me 29 x squared plus
20x now that is not equivalent to this
but it's pretty close because if I take
out a factor of five you can see that
this guy is five outside off
lo and behold 9x
squared plus 20x now you might think how
did I know her to find that what made me
think that there would be something
related between those two the answer is
I'm familiar enough with integration
differentiation to know that if I'm
integrating I'm expecting the reverse
chain rule so the part of that that's
relevant if you think about how the
reverse chain rule works for something
like say this guy over here I've got f
dash X at the front there's my
derivative and f of X inside the
brackets and raised to some power f dash
X and then f of X and I hope you can see
that's exactly what I have here I've got
five lots of f dash X so therefore what
I'm going to write is if f of X is equal
to this 3 X cubed plus 10 x squared etc
then f dash X is equal to 9 x squared
plus 20 X so I'm going to rewrite the
entire integral using this f of X
notation so I've got five lots of f dash
X and then I have f of X raised to a
power in this case it's a power of 3 so
what have I got here what I want really
is for there to be a when I go and do
this simplification I want there to be
an F Dash and F next to each other so
I'll just cut that five at the front
here's F dash and here's F and now what
I'll do is I will raise the index of
that f of X because when I differentiate
the power goes down when I integrate the
how it goes up it's going to be f of X
to the power of 4 and then I divide by
that new index plus of course a constant
of integration because this is an
indefinite integral now I'm pretty much
done I am I can leave this more or less
but I was the one who introduced f of X
not the question so therefore I'll just
substitute it back for what the question
provided that's going to be 3x cubed
plus 10x squared
it's all raised to the power of four and
then it's divided by four now it's true
after doing this amount of work you can
be oh I forgot my constant of
integration you can be quite uncertain
that you've got the answer right so if
you are in the position where you've
finished the paper you're checking
through and making sure that your
answers are correct one of the great
things about every integral is you can
check by differentiating so let's just
because we have some time here let's go
ahead and differentiate this result if I
differentiate five lots of 3x cubed plus
10 x squared all divided by four on four
I'm going to ignore the constant
integration because I know when I
integrate that I'll just get zero let's
begin the process of differentiating I'm
going to get five at that front my index
our four comes down the front so it's
going to be four times 3x cubed plus 10
x squared all to power of three the
index drops down that on four is still
there from the original fraction I'm now
dealt with the outside function
something to the power of four it's
become for something to the power of
three but I still need my inside
function which in this case is I worked
it out just up above yeah it's gonna be
9x squared plus 20x so I'm done with the
differentiation now I just needed to
tidy up firstly I'll cancel those two
fours together and then I notice five
times 9x squared plus 20x suspiciously
becomes forty five x squared plus 100 X
multiplied by my 3x cubed plus 10x
squared to the power of three and you
can see that exactly matches what was in
the original question so if you're ever
in doubt and you have the time
check your integration by
differentiating